what's this nick uh
oh this is uh kinger stinget i thought
it was anna hernandez first
i'm sorry aaron rodgers that's why i
thought you had something for us
aaron rodgers hernandez is who this guy
looks like huh he is from
wisconsin maybe not brendan theo i have
the king
or sting it for you in my wood shop i
like to make
cutting boards and sell them online a
couple years ago i got a
message from a customer that said do you
make charcuterie boards
and i thought to myself listen i'm not
french i have no idea what that word
means
uh over the last couple years
charcuterie has become
popular and i have to say i've been to a
couple weddings it's got dried meats
cheeses nuts berries yeah i know i think
i'm becoming a
charcuterie fan wow anyway king
intersting at shark cuttery boards
gang gang buzz buzz that one's sick yeah
that one kind of hurts my eyes because i
get prison but
yeah that's that honeycomb i'll buy a
cutting board from him and is this one
of his neck
uh that is not this is actually a
complete coincidence my girlfriend made
charcuterie for ufc 252 we had some
friends over here
new place and she's making that this
morning and i'm in the kitchen going
through submissions and this guy popped
up oh wow it was
pretty it was pretty wild thomas didn't
say that what's his company do you know
i'm looking him up yeah i need a new
cutting board
you do yeah let's get one let's get a
couple nicks
his name is david schammer
he didn't leave any other information um
maybe uh by thursday we'll see if he's
got a contact and we'll put it up on the
screen
that's a beautiful little cutting board
yeah now a lot of in
in a lot of asian culture you guys cut
something right in the air right you
guys don't use it
yeah you're not gonna waste yeah
absolutely it's a waste of a dish
yep so you gotta train real hard when
you're a kid we're the original fruit
ninja
damn because now it's an app yeah this
is such a typical white thing we need
like a
safe board to cut on you know um the
salt
salt bae does in the air too though
doesn't he salt bae doesn't like that in
here
yeah he does you know there's a rumor
that he stole that whole thing off of
somebody
what cutting meat huh cutting meat and
salting it
yeah you think i didn't think he was the
original did you
no but doing that a little uh you know
feed the baby deal or whatever oh no
that's
that's in one dog he got that from
basketball did he
yep can you google that uh
salt based steals um
something i think you stole that from
the gay community oh i could see that
dropping that song
[Music]
dude um
damn dude i'm a lawsuit
is somebody actually tip skimming bay
oh chef engaging some shitty wage
practice that is oh he just wasn't
tipping people out
i could see that yeah
tourists are set on fire did that say
that chaos at salt bays
now sobe has restaurants in miami and
new york yeah
ooh hell yeah
four tours are set on fire instagram
star salt-based
istanbul restaurant probably for
what sex before marriage what do they do
over there i don't know what the rules
are
istanbul anyone know about it
no no i think yeah if you're a woman or
you can't drive i guess i don't know
what they did to them
they're trying to get lit on some drinks
and just got out of hand
what do they do is that one they put the
with the flaming uh
huh what is wrong with people man people
can't just [ __ ] eat anymore
are you what is wrong with you guys you
gotta have this guy come over to the
table and do this
you gotta have somebody with a [ __ ]
friend
you gotta have somebody [ __ ] get out
there and beat the [ __ ] out of a sirloin
in front of you
you gotta have somebody drop kick a damn
uh dessert in your mouth like you just
it never ends man people he's trying to
take to the next level
yeah there's always somebody all gotta
like this letter why do you like your
[ __ ] taco like that
what are you doing cat likes it though
it looks fun okay
uh i'd rather not say okay
okay mind-boggling not mind-blowing
it does look like a very sexual
experience for food
but yeah he did stick that finger in a
little too is it
now tell me this is it an asian culture
thing that you guys like more excitement
with the food you guys have the okay
let's eat sushi
denise is back you guys have the let's
do the you know the the skillet in the
air you guys have the
the the experience at the mandarin
kitchen where you guys are cooking the
meat on the grill
benihana is
shrimp in your mother's breast you know
uh
fortune cookies yeah why you can't just
have a regular korean bbq
it's the freshest you can possibly eat
it at that time they cook it and then
boom so that's why i think korean
barbecue
i don't know about vietnamese culture
and flashy stuff there i think it's
something that asians do to try to sell
food to white people that's true
that's another thing okay that's shiny
awkward i think that's a secret and you
know what it worked
it worked really good because i feel
like a lot of non-asians think we're
like mythological creatures as it is so
we just kind of play into it
it's all really a money scheme yep i
like that
now that makes sense
[Music]
is